hey guys it's vadim with max tech and
welcome to our ultimate gaming review of
the brand new 16-inch m1 max macbook pro
with the 32 core gpu 32 gigs of ram and
the one terabyte ssd and what i'm gonna
do in this gaming review is basically go
through all of the different methods for
playing the most popular games on this
macbook pro including using parallels 17
to play overwatch using crossover 21 to
play windows games like grand theft auto
5 witcher 3 and other games like that
and of course i'm gonna play native mac
games like world of warcraft and through
rosetta for different games like dota 2
league of legends and a lot more so
let's go ahead and get into this gaming
review and i do want to mention that
it's currently plugged in right here and
i'm going to go ahead and unplug because
it's at 100 right now and after this
entire gaming session we're gonna see
how much battery life it is left with
and that's what makes this macbook pro
special because you get full performance
even while unplugged which you can't say
for any other windows laptop out there
so as you guys can see i'm currently
running windows 11
right here on this macbook pro bam right
there and the cool thing is with
parallel 17 which i'm using to run
windows 11 you seriously just swipe on
your trackpad now i'm back in mac os bam
i'm back in windows 11. it is so so
convenient and that is why i recommend
parallel 17 for running windows 11 and
if you haven't already checked it out we
have a coupon code below max tech10 to
get 10 off if you try out and buy
parallels which i'd say is awesome and
the best way to do this and the other
best method for playing windows games on
this new macbook pro is crossover 21 by
codeweavers as you can see right here it
works so well as i'm going to show you
later on in this video but if you are
interested in buying this for yourself
it's usually 60 but if you use the link
down in the pinned comment and the
description below you get 25 off so it's
only 45 bucks for an entire year so
here's an example of the coupon code max
tech 25 hit enter boom only 45 dollars
for you guys but i have a surprise for
you i reached out to crossover and they
provided me with three serial keys for
crossover 21 for a full year
subscription and i am gonna give them
away to you guys so all you have to do
is click subscribe and comment down
below and you're entered into the
giveaway and i'm gonna be announcing the
three winners very soon so subscribe
right now but with that said let's go
ahead and get into our gaming test suite
and we're going to start off with the
easier games as i'm about to show you
right now and boom check this out this
is actually rocket league running on
this new m1 max macbook pro and this is
crazy it's using crossover to run
including the heroic app launcher which
you can get a tutorial by checking out
andrew psy's video so definitely do that
but if you didn't already know rocket
league has been basically discontinued
for mac os so you can't play it without
using this crossover 21 method so let's
get right into this guys i don't know
how to play this game so dude i'm
getting such good fps right now
i don't know how to play this dude get
out of here bro wow yeah this is like
seriously good i don't know how much fps
i'm getting but literally no drop frames
and it's insanely smooth it's definitely
above 60 right now like right get it in
boys
yeah
and bam oh look easy oh are you serious
all right let me just show you guys the
uh settings here because
man it just runs so well that there's no
issues at all uh frames per second 120
fps recommended high high 1728 by 1117
that's kind of like 1080p so no issues
with this game let's move on to the next
one all right so somebody asked about
how hearthstone plays and it just plays
so incredibly smooth and easy look at
this i have literally full resolution
3.5 k by 2160 qualities on high and now
i'm in an actual arena match playing
against a real player will 44 and now
we're sitting at around 86 gpu usage so
it's interesting that it went up when
you're actually playing but as you can
see the fan rpm is at 1500 rpms and both
the cpu 61 degrees celsius and the gpu
58 degrees celsius no issues at all
so
awesome
pretty impressive so far
no fan noise at all can't even hear the
fans and well it's your lucky day
because i've gotta move on because this
game is way too easy that of course was
running rosetta translation so it's not
native and it's not optimized for arm so
it's very impressive that we're getting
that performance and now let's turn on
diablo 3 which is also running under
rosetta translation and here we are in
the graphics settings as you can see 16
by 10 native resolution 3.5 k which is
crazy turned off the cap limit for the
fps high textures medium shadows physics
high high full screen anti-aliasing
let's see what we get all right so even
at native res this is absolutely mind
blowing guys native res you could see
150 335 fps look at that okay dip down
for a split second to 79 155 still let's
actually start attacking some mobs but
this is i can't believe it almost 4k
resolution we're playing at guys
with the graphics quality and stuff on
high 130 fps through this literally
you're taking advantage of the new 120
hertz pro motion display like i was not
expecting apple to give us in a 120
hertz display this is so awesome for
gaming am i going to die
oh look at that still over 100
with all of this stuff happening on
screen guys literally no issues oh 99
hello that's too bad 96.
that's still amazing oh oh is that a
legendary sword well
cake i'm gonna turn this off and
actually check out the temps that we're
running at real quick what are we at 90
degrees for the cpu and the gpu but the
fans were only at 2700 so that was only
about 25 33 of the way so like running
that game at 3.5 k was not maxing out
the fans or anything
barely barely audible like just barely
now i'm in starcraft 2 i'm just going to
play against ai just so i don't have to
match up with anybody but let's test out
the fps here all right so this fps
overlay is very very tiny i can barely
see it but i'm sitting around 106 fps
right now 100 607 so this is definitely
not inside an actual i guess firefight
just yet but if we look at our graphics
settings we're literally sitting at
native 3.5 k resolution which is
absolutely insane with the graphics
quality set to custom basically
everything is maxed out except for the
shaders which i think going above medium
just totally messes with the fps and it
just ruins it so i'm staying at medium
shaders with everything else maxed out
even the resolution even though it
recommends 1920 still sitting at a
hundred what is that 120 fps guys 120
fps at native res i
can't believe it it's crazy
micromanaging
all right now that we're fighting we're
getting down to 90 fps right here but
it's yup 90fps guys let me actually turn
down the settings
to what it recommended 1920 by 1200
there you go look at that
it didn't make that big of a difference
now we're at 100
while we're doing all this 1920 by 1200
115 right there guys so starcraft
easy and now with that said let's get
into world of warcraft which is
basically the first
native built for arm metal game there is
so this is gonna be interesting by the
way guys
the speakers
on these macbook pros are so good
literally
oh hear that bass
literally the best speakers on any
laptop ever with this 16 inch right here
yeah come on
wow oh my goodness look at this you guys
seen this 173 fps 175 that is a lot of
headroom in case you're actually playing
at the higher levels in raids or
dungeons there's a ton of headrooms
check it out guys full screen native
resolution 3456 by 2234 that's 3.5 k
i've got the graphics quality to seven
you know what
let's go all out let's go to 10. what do
we get at 10 at literally 3.5 k
resolution which is crazy look at that
100 fps right now
you guys seen that 100 fps 95. there you
go 1920 by 1240 that's a little bit
higher than 1080p in terms of the pixel
count and what do we get
180 fps this is more realistic and this
is probably what somebody should be
running this at just to have the extra
leeway and extra headroom for those
crazy raids and dungeons but guys
i am so impressed with the performance
of this
native game and now i can actually hear
the fans
but i have to get up close to hear them
it's kind of funny i can hear them right
now but the sound of our ac is louder
which is kind of funny now what i want
to do really quick is check out
the temps that we're running this at
let's see 99 gpu so we're maxing it out
82 degrees was the highest i saw right
there
while running world of warcraft so 82
degrees celsius on the gpu
and 3500 rpms on the fans that's about
halfway a little bit tiny bit over
halfway in terms of the maximum speed
fan speed and just to show you guys how
well this is running i'm gonna click the
maximum fan speed button and you guys
can actually hear it check this out
there you go
now you can hear the maximum fan speed
so this is actually impressive that
world of warcraft is running that well
with a hundred percent gpu load
with 32 gpu cores and now of course i
switched it back to system
and i could barely hear it alright world
of warcraft is also too easy let's get
into something a little bit more
difficult and of course here we are
using crossover 21 to run the windows
version of steam and once again if
you're gonna be impressed by this
performance we have the coupon code max
tech 25 below in the pin comment in
description if you want to get 25 off
and yes i'm about to play grand theft
auto 5 on this macbook pro so let's get
right into it and i do want to mention
that to get this running properly i did
have to sign up as a beta tester with
crossweavers and download the latest
nightly build which is basically beta
but this should be built into the
regular version very soon all right guys
look at this running using crossover
previously we had to use parallels but
now they've optimized it and crossover
can actually run it which is awesome
because since you're not doing it
through a vm
you do get more fps and look at this i
unfortunately don't have an fps counter
but you guys are watching 4k 60 right
here fps it's not perfect but it's
probably around what 50 60 something
like that and just to show you guys we
were running at 1920 by 1200 that's
higher than 1080p so if i really wanted
to i could turn it down a bit 1280x800
if we really wanted to i could turn it
down a bit 1280 by 800 if we really want
to get that extra
fps boost and there you go the quality
looks like garbage
quality is not good but the fps i mean
i'm getting perfect 60 at least right
now now the crazy thing about the latest
crossover update is you can actually
play gta online which you weren't able
to do before so let's jump into it and
while the online mode is loading i do
want to mention that we just got in our
brand new maxtec soc hoodie as you can
see right here so if you're thankful for
all the crazy hard work and extra hours
we've been putting in this last couple
of weeks to get you guys all of these
comparison videos and reviews and
everything else if you want to show your
support you can find this down in the
merge shelf below this video thank you
guys check it out
gta online
would you look at that guys survival
i'll just play by myself i'm doing this
job on my own whatever
let's jump into it yeah so the quality
is not that great but it is playable i
don't think it's running at 60fps on the
online mode i think it is a little bit
more intensive oh we got dudes
get him bro oh no these guys are trying
to kill me
oh hey
there you go i can't believe we're
playing grand theft auto online and
we're not even plugged in this is
absolutely crazy and
the fans
i literally cannot hear the fans gpu is
only at 42 percent
60 degrees celsius on the gpu like what
is going on 70 degrees for the cpu
fans are idling at 1 500 rpm
so looks like it could handle even more
load now moving on another windows game
i have installed is the witcher 3 wild
hunt this is of course running through
crossover but before i show you guys
this game i want to go through a couple
of requested games that are running
under rosetta emulation so let's get
right into that first as you can see i
have the mac os version of steam open
right here and i have dota 2 path of
exile and counter strike go so let's do
doto 2 first here we are in the graphics
settings and i've set it to the best
looking basically maxing out all the
graphics and i've also set it to 2.5 k
so 2560 by
1600 for the resolution let's go ahead
and get into a game and test out the fps
alright guys remember we maxed out the
settings i don't know if you can see
that fps counter right there 115
117 fps 102 that is extremely impressive
for what we just set it to i think it
just jumped down to 78 for a split
second there so we'll have to see if we
have to turn down the resolution a
little bit because 2.5 k
that's pretty good resolution even while
fighting this dude
still sitting at a 96 fps i just saw it
dip to if i wanted to i could easily
just turn down the resolution and i'll
get like i don't know you know what
let's try it 1920x1200
yo why am i over here dude all right i
turned down the resolution a little bit
and it looks like it didn't make a
difference
103 fps still like what
oh 82 what why is it going down maybe it
doesn't really matter what resolution
you're playing at you know what let's do
full 3.5 k wow this is tiny like that
fps counter just became so small 87 at
95 fps at full native resolution 3.5 k
this game is insane it's pretty good
optimization for
running under rosetta 100 fps still guys
with that said let's go ahead and move
on to counter strike go and see what
kind of fps we can get here all right
getting into it looks like we're at what
is that 66 oh 100 fps
got him 71 85 fps all right now in the
warm up we're sitting at 97 109 fps 116
guys that's pretty impressive so far 98.
oh that was a little bit glitchy right
there i saw it go down to like what 60
something
oh mexican stuff what
oh i got you oh man these guys are
everywhere cool got them
oh
we got me oh man this so far this is
good performance guys 69 fps all right
so let me show you guys the settings
right now video
1920x1200 so it's scaled down a little
bit i've got the graphics settings at
around
medium basically on everything
1920x1200
looks great not the best fbs but hey
we're running without issues i don't
think i've seen it below 60.
oh oh gotcha
oh gotcha
i haven't seen it below 60 which is
exactly what you want
2560 by 1600
let's try that out all right the fps
counter just got tiny look at that 78
fps 80 fps wow
so you can go higher on the resolution
and not really get that big of a hit
that's 2.5 k res guys
2.5 k resolution we just hit 100 again
and let me just close this off and let's
see what we're running at for the temps
66 degrees celsius for the gpu 77 for
the gpu 1500 rpms for the fans they're
still literally idling i literally can't
even hear them path of exile let's get
into this next game here we are in the
settings i've turned off these fps caps
where in full screen mode vsync is
disabled
and here are the settings ultra shadows
hi basically everything the lighting
everything's maxed out except for the
global illumination i didn't turn that
on anti-aliasing is off as default a lot
of this on high texture filtering so
everything's pretty good and i've turned
off the dynamic resolution so it doesn't
turn anything down but here we are and
as it turns out it looks like we're
getting hard capped
to 60 fps i try to do a little bit of
research and it looks like that cap
stays consistent and let me switch to
windowed mode really quick and yes we
are playing online we can see some
people talking
in the chat right there
and uh yeah
no issues solid 60 fps capped it won't
let us go above that for some reason but
and here you can see the gpu 72 degrees
celsius definitely not hot
96 gpu load no issues
fans 3 200 rpms i can just barely hear
them but of course my ac is still louder
so i have to get close to here though
man even in this game no hiccups and i
know you guys want to see minecraft
so here it is let's play some minecraft
and this is actually running under
rosetta translation there is a way that
you can actually run some scripts and do
some setup process to actually get a
metal native version running but i
didn't think it was worth it because the
performance is already so good here we
are in the settings you can see our
render resolution 3.5 k
native 5x5 normal on that graphics set
to fast smooth lighting maximum render
distance five chunks maximum frame rate
120 let's actually turn that up
there you go vsync is off
let's set this to 10 clouds set to fancy
and here we are guys
with the view distance to 10 you can see
pretty far away like that's probably
like more than good enough 117 fps 102
122 right there and we're just looking
around look at that guys we're taking
advantage of that pro motion display 143
140 and keep in mind that this is not
running the metal version i heard that
you could actually get double the fps
if you go through that process with
minecraft which is probably going to
help out if you want to do a lot of mods
and other stuff like that which is
intensive or of course you can just
download this regular version and just
turn down some of the settings
and you'll be good to go no issues at
all and that was so easy that the fans
were literally idling and now of course
one of the most popular games out there
league of legends which is running over
rosetta so let's go ahead and get right
into it already we're loading in right
now and if you guys appreciate all the
work we're doing and this gaming review
please subscribe right now to help us
reach a million subs before the end of
the year we would really really
appreciate it all right we're maxing
everything out let's go increase the
quality literally everything maxed out
native 3.5 k almost 4k resolution the
highest you can get highest quality
let's see what we get currently sitting
at 92
91 fps guys at this insane resolution
everything looks amazing 69 65 fps there
oh you suck dude
still didn't get below 60 as far as i
know this is just insane that we're at
native 3.5 k resolution everything maxed
out no glitches and there's just so much
headroom
you suck flatbot
now just for fun i'm going to turn down
the settings to basically medium right
in the middle 1920 by 1200 still decent
fps that's higher than 1080p gaming just
to see
what difference we can get in fps right
we're above 100 right now guys above 100
1080p gaming medium settings 117 120 fps
right there look at that
taking full advantage
of the pro motion display that is
beautiful 56 degrees on the gpu the fans
1500 rpms they're idling again and now
let's get into something a little bit
more difficult the witcher 3 running
using cross over now this is one of the
games that we were able to play with the
m1 max but the fps wasn't that great
with the settings turned down so let's
see how the m1 max does alright here we
are in crossover looks like decent fps
we are getting some little bit of
stuttering
now if we do notice stuttering i do want
to mention that this is doing a lot of
translation
first of all it's translating
vulcan into metal so there's a
translation layer there and then on top
of that it's translating x86 code that
was written for windows into arm using
rosetta so multiple layers of
translation
to basically get this
pretty decent fps everything looks great
now to show you guys the graphics
settings we're at 1728 by 1080 full
screen got a lot of this stuff on low
actually since we're doing all that
translation oh here we go
let's go wolf oh snap but yeah it's
awesome that we can play windows games
like this
you know
on mac os using crossover man it's such
a good app and even with that game the
fans were also idling so you can't even
hear them that is just so impressive
with these really cool
m1 max chips now the downside
of mac os and moving over to these arm
based
m1 ships is that unfortunately you are
limited in the game support so you can't
play all the games out there because
crossover doesn't support all the games
like for example destiny 2 which does
not work through crossover because these
arm chips do not support certain
anti-cheat systems which is very
unfortunate but hopefully that gets
fixed and hopefully they start
supporting mac os and these new chips
very soon and with crossover directx 12
games do not work just yet but code
weavers did mention that they are
working on directx support so hopefully
next year sometime we'll be able to play
those games with crossover and finally
the last game that i want to test is
actually under parallels 17 and it's the
only way to run it so let's go ahead and
launch it and yes i'm talking about
overwatch this is a windows only game
and it's running through parallels which
is just beautiful let's go ahead and
play here we are in the settings for
overwatch and i've turned down the
resolution because i was experiencing
some drop frames 16 by 10 limit fps off
so let's go ahead and get into some
gameplay all right here we are as you
can see we have our temps right here 87
gpu 68 cpu this is running under a vm
virtual machine so it's literally
virtually running windows and then
running this game on top of it which is
just mind-blowing that you're able to do
this alright here we are in game
so far you can see the fps counter up
there 80 fps
and it does have some stuttering
sometimes just dropped to 45 graphics
quality definitely does not look good
alright guys oh man this is so
so bad this is basically unplayable
i'm getting so much stuttering right now
i don't even know
what's going on almost feels like once
it loads a section of the map it gets
better
yeah and this of course isn't pointing
to these macs not having enough power
because as you can see the fans are
literally idling 1 500 rpm gp usage only
at 66
69 degrees celsius on the graphics
so it's really the
translation that's making this game not
run that well but even now it's actually
doing decent so it's like once you load
a part of the map it does a lot better
actually that's interesting yeah i mean
look
better fps right now we're sticking to a
section that's still pre-loaded which is
nice yeah it's like when we get into the
areas of the map that aren't loaded we
get a lot more issues so i wonder if you
just walk through the entire map you'll
get actually decent
fps so not bad so with all that said and
all of those games played with the
different methods like native rosetta
parallels and crossover i've got to say
that i'm extremely impressed with these
new m1 max macbook pros the 16 inch
model i've barely heard the fans spin up
during this testing which is insane you
don't get that with windows gaming
laptops and i'm just so impressed
because you can reach 120 fps in a lot
of those games
and if you don't just turn down the
settings a little bit so this can legit
be a gaming laptop the only issue is
that not all games are supported just
yet hopefully we get a lot better
support over the next year as more
developers jump on and things like that
and with that said after playing for
more than a couple hours probably two
and a half hours we're still left with
36 percent battery life we played
unplugged throughout all of that so guys
i've got to say i'm extremely impressed
with this macbook pro it's just doing so
well in these games and this is actually
my own personal macbook pro so i can
finally replace a desktop pc and play
the games i want to play like i've
really wanted to play league of legends
and other games like that so awesome job
apple but there you go hopefully you
enjoyed this gaming review and if you
did definitely use those links below in
the description and the pinned comment
for the discounts for parallels and
crossover definitely hit subscribe so
you don't miss out on more videos like
this one to help us reach a million subs
before the end of the year watch one of
those two videos right there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]